the protesters did have successes
turning small numbers into a big voice
and forcing governments to respond we're
going to win there was sympathy for what
many genuinely endured i'm out here
because i've been hurt so much by this
by these mandates that i can't take it
anymore but in one crucial way they fell
short failing to spark a groundswell to
turn around majority opinion for many
the tactics were off-putting
[Music]
and demands for immediate policy changes
seemed unrealistic the mandates are
still here so i'm not going most
canadians are fed up with restrictions i
genuinely understand the frustration but
saw them as a necessary evil everyone in
this country has to make sacrifices to
keep ourselves safe to keep everyone
else safe
we're canadian we're not just a country
of individuals
one guy on his ottawa balcony was turned
into a mock heritage minute profanely
telling convoy protesters to just go
home walk around with your tailgate
party
the vast majority of canadians accepted
the science that underpinned vaccination
campaigns and other measures british
columbia still has restrictions that the
premier says have made a difference we
have been driven from the beginning on
the best available science to protect
people the policies were designed to
save lives and keep hospitals from being
overwhelmed vaccinations certainly have
made a difference in hospitalizations
this infectious disease expert does say
in hindsight mandates were coercive and
says lockdowns and how people were
affected should be examined for next
time there has been a significant
erosion of trust that's happened while
protesters have called for freedom
others say vaccines restored the freedom
to go out and feel safe for doing so
that freedom of choice on vaccines
ignores the risks there's no such thing
as total freedom even people who choose
to get unvacciated we society pays for
their hospital bills we generally live
in a society where we have to make
concessions for the greater good
the protests have revealed deep rifts in
the country and even the police
crackdown is triggering a necessary
debate but the larger story of the
pandemic is two years of collective
perseverance by canadians that is
gradually seeing health restrictions
finally lifted which is what everyone
wants
eric sorensen global news toronto